Transcriber: Abd alrahman shiban
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
كل سنة،
كنت كل أربع أو خمس سنوات
أعيد تعريف نفسي أمام نفسي وأمام الآخرين.
لكن هناك محطات أساسية بحياة
كل شخص منّا،
صعب علينا أن نتخطاها أو ننساها.
في عام 2012، كنتُ أغادر
أول مؤسسة حقيقية عملت فيها.
كنت أسمع كلامًا كثيرًا يُقال من خلفي،
ما الذي تريد أن تفعله في هذا الوقت؟
مَن تعتقد نفسها؟
وما الذي ستفعله لوحدها؟
رجال لم يستطيعوا القيام بأي شيء،
أو إذا تحدثت بالفعل، مَن سيسمعها؟
مَن الذي يسمع المذياع حاليًا؟
طبعًا ليست هذه هي الأسباب
التي جعلتني أترك العمل،
ليست هذه هي المرة الأولى
التي أودع نسرين فيها،
أو بالأحرى أعيد تعريفها.
إذا عدنا معاً إلى الوقت
الذي كنتُ أبلغ فيه 18 عامًا،
أتذكر أول نسرين قمت بوداعها
على باب مدرسة التجارة الثالثة للبنات،
تركتها هنالك تذيع عناوين
الصحف الرئيسية والأخبار بين الحصص،
وكانت تتنقل بين أغاني فيروز
ووديع الصافي.
كان من الطبيعي جداً أن تخطب
نصف عدد طالبات صف الثانوية.
لأن حظوظ الفتيات المنتسبات
للتعليم المهني
أقل من حظوظ الفتيات
المنتسبات للتعليم العام
بإكمال دراستهن بعد ختام
مرحلة التعليم الثانوي.
ماذا سيكون مستقبلهن؟
سكرتيرات، خياطات؟
وأكيد هذا لم يكن خيارًا مقبولًا
عند عدد كبير من العائلات السورية.
وأعتقد أن الأمر إلى الآن كما هو.
إلّا إذا كّن محظوظات وتقدم عرسان إليهن.
أنا كنت من المحظوظات
وتقدم لي عريس، وعريس جيّد.
لكن لم أكن فقط محظوظة
لأن عريسًا تقدم لي,
كنت محظوظة لأن والدي أصرّ أن أنهي
مرحلة الثانوية أولًا,
وأيضًا استطاع أن ينتزع وعدًا من زوجي
بأن أكمل دراستي بعد الزواج.
في سوريا،
إلى عام 2017،
كان يتم تزويج الفتيات بعمر 13 سنة.
وهذه الحالات كانت تتم برضا الأهل،
وبموافقة ومباركة القاضي
وتحت سقف القانون.
في كلِّ مرة كنت فيها أقابل فتاة،
فتاة طفلة تحمل على يدها ابنها أو بنتها،
كنت فوراً أتلمّس يدي.
لأن هذه اليد التي مسكها والدي
يوم زفافي وخطبتي وقال لي: “أنا معك“.
وكنت أشاهد كتفي الذي سنده زوجي،
وأخبرني أنه عند وعدهُ لي.
كنت أتساءل: “يا ترى كم فتاة
وجدت يد مثل ما وجدتُ أنا يدًا أمسكها؟،
وكم فتاة وجدت كتفًا يسندها؟،
ماذا حصل لها
بعد أن تُركت لمصير الزواج المبكّر؟.
والذي الكثير ينظر إليه على أنه أمر طبيعي،
وأصلًا هي محظوظة جدًا.
لازلت أحسُّ بالعجز اتجاه هؤلاء الفتيات
في كل تحقيق أو مقال كنت أنجزه،
أو حلقة تلفازية أعرضها مباشرة.
إلى أن تم رفع سن الزواج في سوريا.
تم تعديل السن ليصبح 18 عام.
مع ذلك إلى الآن، أنظر إلى هذا القانون
بأنه مازال مقصّرًا اتجاه هؤلاء الفتيات.
في كل مرة كنت أشعر فيها
أنني أبتعد عن نفسي،
كنت أرجع أكتب وأمسك ورقة وقلم
وأكثر من الشطب وأكتب.
كتبت حكايات وقصص لكن لم أنشرهم.
كنت أكتبهم لنفسي،
لأذكّر نفسي بنفسي.
لا أنسى في عام 2016،
عندما طردني أحد رجال الدين.
لأنه أعتقد أنني أتحدى الحدود المرسومة لي.
ضرب يده على الطاولة،
وقال لي: “أخرجي،
حَقّ اللّه العام لا تقربيه”
عندها أنا أخبرته: “يوم القيامة “.
شعر وقتها أنني تعديت حدودي،
لأنني كنت أطالب بحق بنات بلدي،
بأن يسلجوا أطفالهن على اسمهن.
في ذلك الوقت أخبرته، “أننا نحن يوم القيامة
سوف ننادى بأسماء أمهاتنا،
لماذا لا تعطونا هذا الحق على الأرض؟،
أنتم لستم أكرم من اللَّه“.
في الوقت الذي كان فيه أهلي
يعرفون ما الذي أكتبه،
كانوا يقولون لي: “ماعلاقتك بالموضوع؟،
هذا ليس من شأنك،
ما الذي تستطعين فعله؟”
صراحةً لم أكن قادرة على نسيان
وجه السيدة التي قابلتها في دائرة النفوس.
موظفة النفوس حملت أوراقها
وقامت برميهم في وجهها،
وقالت لها: “أخرجي،
لن أسجل الطفل حتى أرى والده أمامي“.
علمًا أنَّ السيدة متزوجة زواجًا صحيحًا
ولديها دفتر عائلة يثبت زواجها.
مع ذلك لم توافق الموظفة
على تسجيل الطفل.
أو كيف أنسى صوت السيدة التي قالت لي:
“أقول لهم أنني زانية
أقول كيفما يريدون،
أريد فقط أن يسجلوا لي ابني
حتى أقدر أن أحصل على صندوق طعام كمعونة“.
في ذلك الوقت، أخبرها محامي
أنَّ القانون السوري يسجّل واقعة الطفل
في حال أخبرتهم والدته
أنه ناتج عن واقعة زنا.
في ذلك الوقت، كان مطلوب مني الصمت،
لأننا نحن الآن في حالة حرب،
ولا يوجد وقت لهذه الأشياء.
لكن الذي كان بالنسبة لي كنسرين،
وكصحفية وزوجة وأم وامرأة.
أن يكون لي في هذا الوقت
أول تحقيق استقصائي،
عنوانه “أطفال بلا نسب“.
بعدما انتشر هذا التحقيق،
في فترة قليلة جدًا تقريبًا شهرين.
تحركت أصوات داخل مجلس الشعب،
وكان هنالك قانون سيقرُّ
عن حقوق الأطفال والأسرة.
تعلمون في تلك اللحظة
التي كان الجميع يشاهد فيها هذا التحقيق،
والناس تقوم بمشاركته
والاتصال للتحدث معي.
انا بقيتُ مدة ساعة من الزمن جالسة
ورابط التحقيق أمامي،
لم اتجرأ على فتحه،
لأنني علمتُ أنني قد تجاوزت الحدود
التي كانت مرسومة لي.
لكن عندما فتحت الرابط،
وقرأت التحقيق،
عدتُ لتعريف نفسي أمام نفسي وأمام الآخرين.
في كثير من الأماكن كان يُقال لي:
“ماذا تريدين من هذا الأمر؟،
اكتبي عن القمامة، عن الماء،
عن الخبز [غير مسموع]
مثل الخبز والكهرباء.
اكتبي عن هذه القصص في حال
عدم كتابتك عن المجال الفني“.
علماً أن العمل في القسم الفنّي صعب
وليس بهذه السهولة.
في ذلك الوقت كنتُ أرد بتحقيقات
تعتبر من العيار الثقيل،
وحصلتُ على ثناءات.
لكن من النوع الثاني.
هذا الشيء الذي دفعني
لاحقًا لعدم الاستمرار.
في كثير من الأماكن،
وفي الوقت الذي كنتُ أرى فيه نحن النساء
ماذا يمكننا أن نعمل؟
هل تعلموا مقدار المعاناة
التي نواجهها نحن النساء العاملات
في الصحافة والإعلام والفن والتمثيل،
أو حتى إن رغبتم في جميع المجالات،
حنى نقدرُ أن نُثبت
أننا نستحق الشيء الذي وصلنا إليه.
لأن أكثر وأسهل ما يُقال للمرأة الناجحة:
“ماذا قدّمتِ وماذا فعلتِ؟”
وإذا كان هنالك فتاة جميلة
لن تستطيع أن تتخلص من اتهامات:
مع مَن نامت؟
وما هو مقدار ما عرضته من جسمها؟
وماذا فعلت لكي تكون ناجحة.
لم تتوقف كتاباتي عند قضايا المرأة.
كنت أحاول الكتابة
عن كل خطأ تقع عيناي عليه،
كتبتُ عن زراعة المخدرات في سوريا،
انتقدت قانون التعليم الإلزامي،
وكتبتُ أيضًا عن العشوائيات والانتخابات،
وكتبت عن الإدارة المحلية.
كل هذا كان حتى أستطيع في كل مرة
أن أكون قادرة على تعريف نفسي بنفسي.
في كل لحظة من حياتي
عندما أعود لتعريف نفسي،
كنتُ أرى مسارين:
مسار يمكن أغلب النساء الموجودات
اليوم في القاعة الاحساس به
مسار مرسوم بوضوح،
زوجة، أم، ربّة منزل،
امرأة عاملة، لا مشكلة.
وهنالك مسار ثاني كانت النساء تختاره،
تختار أن تقوم هي برسمه.
مثل ما الفرع الذي سنقوم بدراسته؟
أو ما القضية التي سنحملها؟
أو ما المعركة التي سنخضوها؟
وكيف سنخوضها؟
أو حتى إن رغبتم ما هو
عدد الأطفال الذين سننجبهم؟
وإن كنا نرغبُ في إنجاب أطفال أو لا؟.
هذه المسارات موجودة دون أن يكون هناك
أحكام مسبقة للنساء،
دون أن يتم إخبارهم بكلام
متل الكلام الذي سمعته عام 2012:
“اجعلوها تنضب”
دعونا ننظر إلى المثال الثاني،
لنفكر جميعنا فيه معًا،
رجال ونساء، صغار وكبار،
محجبات وغير محجبات،
متعلمين وغير متعلمين، طوال وقصار
دعونا ننظر إلى هذه المسارات
التي استطاعت النساء معرفتها
وقامت بتعريفها.
استطعن معرفتها بأدوار
لم يستطعن خوضها من قبل.
وفي قضايا كان يُقال لهن أنها ليست لهن،
في أدوار قمن بها وكن فيها صانعات القرار،
كنّ فيها مفاوضات، رائدات أعمال
وزيرات، سكرتيرات،
سائقات طائرات وسائقات سيارات.
هذه المسارات،
الناجحة،
كانت ناجحة لأنها كانت تُبنى بالشراكة،
كان يتم بناؤها شكل جماعي.
ومن خلال هذه المسارات استطاعت النساء
نقل مجتمعاتها لأماكن أحسن ومواقع أفضل.
هذه المسارات كانت ناجحة
لأنه لم يُرسم للنساء حدود معينة.
ولم يكن يُقال لها ابقِ في المنزل.
هذاا المسار الذي أريد دعوتكم جميعًا
لمعاودة التفكير فيه.
كيف نستطيع أن نبني مساراتنا
حتى نستطيع تحسين هذا الواقع معًا،
ونصل إلى أماكن لندعو فيه زميلاتي
قبل أن أكون موجودة،
مثل ما كانت تقوله أميرة
ومتل ما كان يقلن كل الصبايا من قبل.
أتمنى من الموجودين هنا
والموجودين في الخارج,
أن نعود لنتشارك في بناء هذه المسارات
لنشاهد مسارات جديدة
نستحقها نحن النساء السوريات
ومجتمعنا السوري ككل.
(تصفيق)